[Musique]
Véronique que l'on retrouve Hélène et
Christian bonsoir
au panel puis sans surprise Véronique
monsieur Legault a dit ben non on va pas
rentrer obligatoire en fait je suis en
parler avec une source qui était bien
impliquée durant la pandémie une source
du gouvernement un petit peu plutôt
avant d'aller en nombre qui me disait ce
serait techniquement simple demain
d'arriver au Conseil des ministres
signer un décret on retourne en urgence
sanitaire mais ce serait
philosophiquement très difficile au
niveau de l'acceptabilité surtout que le
gouvernement a pris un engagement et
c'est vraiment ça qui est important
parce que rappelez-vous la loi qui
mettait fin à l'urgence sanitaire qui a
été adopté au début de l'été et qui
permettait au gouvernement de se garder
les pouvoirs résiduels jusqu'à la fin de
jusqu'au 31 décembre mais au fur et à
mesure que des choses qu'on laissait
tomber comme par exemple le masque on y
a mis fin
de le porter de façon obligatoire le 14
mai donc au fur et à mesure qu'on
élimine des pouvoirs on peut pas les
ramener que la loi prévoit donc ce
serait de briser un engagement important
et clairement le gouvernement veut aller
là vraiment dernier recours et on peut
conseiller Hélène comme l'Ontario comme
d'autres le font conseiller sur une
chose obligé s'en est une autre en fait
on revient à ces critères là quoi oui je
pense que politiquement la situation
doit être à peu près la même partout au
Canada ou presque c'est politiquement
suicidaires en fait de revenir avec ces
mesures alors que les citoyens en ont
assez moi je dirais seulement que si
j'avais à Paris sur qui serait le
premier à ramener ça si quelqu'un devait
ramener ça j'aurais tendance à croire
que peut-être ce serait le gouvernement
fédéral le gouvernement fédéral pour qui
le bon l'obligation du masque et
s'applique essentiellement au
fonctionnaires fédéraux et aussi les
voyageurs dans les trains et les avions
rappelez-vous quand même que cette
obligation de porter le masque dans les
trains et les avions elle n'est tombée
que le 1er octobre dernier c'est c'était
c'est tout récent de ne pas mais c'est
aussi à une période il y avait presque
plus de mesures sanitaires en vigueur
nulle part ailleurs au Canada donc le
gouvernement fédéral de Justin Trudeau
haute nu lol la ligne jusqu'au bout et
donc ça pourrait être celui-là qui
serait le premier à retomber dans cette
logique sanitaire si et si évidemment
oui Christian
je trouve que sauf répétition du
cataclysme mondial qu'on a vécu il y a
deux ans et demi là où tout basculer en
trois ans je pense que le masque
obligatoire ça a déclencherait des
réactions extrêmement négatives au sein
de la population ça rappelle un
cauchemar un backtrip on est vraiment
plus là-dedans quel que soit les
recommandations je dirais même des
médecins cela dit le masque qui
recommandé beaucoup de gens disent au
fond c'est bidons les gens le porteront
pour moi je suis pas d'accord je suis
venu ici en métro tout à l'heure à
Montréal j'étais frappé de voir à quel
point il y a beaucoup de gens portaient
le masque dans le métro parce qu'on sait
que une épidémie de grippe puis à la
covid il me semble ce sur quoi il
faudrait travailler c'est que
actuellement il faut être réaliste là le
masque garder une image négative parce
que ça rappelle la pandémie c'est
peut-être de rappeler que c'est pas
juste négatif c'est que dans l'avenir
quand on est grippé quand on a des
problèmes c'est bien de porter le masque
que ça protège les os je pense que le
travail à faire là dessus et dans le
métro je vois moi j'étais étonné j'ai
dit que beaucoup de monde qui porte
volontairement et l'autre et c'est là
toute la différence entre le volontaire
et le bien obligatoire les gens veulent
plus rien savoir moi le premier très
bien une conférence de presse demain
Véronique on verra ils vont beaucoup
inciter sur la vaccination aussi on va
suivre ça demain bon on a connu
Christian vous êtes un peu plus âgé et
moi aussi j'ai connu des des schisme
dans les partis politiques pour des
questions idéologiques des départs au PQ
à l'époque Parisot et les autres on a
connu le départ de
plus on recule de René l'évêque du PLQ
Mario Dumont du PLQ pour des questions
idéologique pour des chips on arrachait
les cheveux et là on se retrouve au
Parti libéral du Québec avec des départs
des pas vraiment des quand je reviendrai
pas maintenant puis finalement pour des
questions d'égo de postes qu'est-ce qui
se passe je fais entendre d'abord
quelques extraits de la journée entre
autres le chef Internet
il y a jamais eu de dire pour apprendre
votre expression ce qu'il y a eu c'est
une avenue à explorer et cette avenue a
exploré là j'aurais tout tenté j'aurais
tout essayé c'est une chose inédite sans
précédent et évidemment il devait y
avoir des vérifications à faire par la
suite et rapidement j'ai fait le choix
de la cohésion d'équipe cette solution
là n'était pas viable et j'en ai informé
Marie-Claude
avec les jeunes nouveaux addictiques
sont là j'essaie de d'unifier l'équipe
présentement un énorme travail à faire
puis je vais le faire j'ai un défi
devant moi
le toute cette histoire est derrière moi
et derrière nous et avec mes collègues
du Parti libéral du Québec nous allons
travailler pour amener des réponses
concrètes à l'Assemblée nationale pour
l'ensemble des Québécoises des Québécois
bon pour se retrouver là Véronique
Franck Benjamin qu'on vient de
d'entendre finalement on voulait lui
dire prends tes 4 ans de troisième
vice-président l'Assemblée nationale
donne en deux en lame de cause on
partage ça tout va bien ça c'était hier
soir les petits oiseaux chantaient tout
le monde revenait or il a dit non moi
j'ai pas accepté ça alors là il y a
refusé il y a lui-même aurait menacé
Véronique de quitter le caucus ok
qu'est-ce qu'on assiste à quoi là moi en
fait j'ai jamais vu ça honnêtement
partie libéral là c'est un parti qui est
réputé où tout le monde est dans le rang
et là tout à l'heure là c'était sûr
réaliste qu'on est entré au caucus je
trouve que les images même en ondes
reflètent pas réellement ce qu'on
sentait sur place tellement l'atmosphère
était tendu parce que là on voyait le
chef intérimaire entrer dans le caucus
plus vous aviez les nouveaux qui
applaudissaient très fort parce que eux
c'est une première expérience un focus
professionnel au salon rouge et tout ça
puis vous avez les anciens avec qui
avait pratiquement une phase de carême
quasiment ça paraissait qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui allait pas du tout
et on pouvait presque se demander si
aujourd'hui c'est un focus professionnel
ou une thérapie de groupe ou un mélange
des deux là parce que honnêtement
c'était très tendu je trouvais à la
situation ouais Hélène
qui pourrait dire aux deux et Benjamin
Nicole bon ben partez vous deux on va
essayer de refaire on en est où d'après
vous comme de d'un peu plus loin comment
vous voyez ça ben en tout cas je pense
que ça a été une erreur de présenter le
débat l'expulsion et puis peut-être la
réintégration de Madame Nicoz comme un
test de leadership pour Dominique
Anglade en fait c'était finalement un
prétexte parce que là on le voit bien
confronté à un nouveau chef monsieur
Tanguay elle n'a pas davantage plié
cette madame Nicoz et en fait on
comprend qu'elle est inflexible
intransigeante que qu'elle a un certain
niveau de caprice exprimé elle veut
obtenir ce qu'elle désire et sans quoi
elle claque la porte alors j'ai une
petite pensée pour Dominique je me dis
que finalement tout ça n'était qu'un
prétexte parce qu'on voulait avoir
plus critique envers madame Nicole à
l'époque je veux jouer je vous donne
quand même ce crédit-là
je trouve que quand même le ça
m'apparaît ne pas avoir de grandes
convictions politiques et eux de la part
de mes courses mais aussi de la part de
Monsieur Benjamin maintenant de nous
dire que on voit claquer la porte du
caucus simplement parce qu'on a pas eu
notre poste de prédilection écoutez et
là ça donne l'impression d'un parti de
de privilégier ou en tout cas qu'on
tient à nos privilèges parce que être un
vice-président de la Chambre ça vient
avec des privilèges quand même et c'est
pas très fort en principe ça envoie une
très mauvaise image en tout cas du Parti
libéral en ce moment c'est comme s'il
restait que des piccadilles l'artifice
et que l'essence du parti les idées les
combats qu'on veut mener il y en a plus
alors comme il y en a plus on fera
baisse toi tu as quoi tu as trois
mais mais on nous apprenait à l'époque
que en politique en fait la fonction la
plus noble et de l'Ouest est député de
représenter les électeurs soit on
assiste actuellement là c'est pas
glorieux parce qu'il se battent pour des
fonctions honorifiques qui rapportent
35000 pièces par année faut-il le dire
donc ça ça conforte en fait les plus
jeux que beaucoup de gens ont regardé
politiciens en effet qui sont pas ils
sont là pour leur intérêt et pas pour
l'intérêt public et celui moi je trouve
qu'il devrait avoir le dernier mot c'est
Jean-Claude rivet a lancé un député
libéral de Jean-Talon qui était sénateur
à Ottawa aussi c'était un compagnon de
route de Monsieur Bourassa vous vous en
souvenez il a écrit sa page Facebook au
sujet de Madame bernicole Marie-Claude
on dit que vous êtes une excellente
député
occupez-vous de votre côté merci
je trouve que c'est Jean-Claude rivet
qui a raison c'est des divas c'est des
querelles des gosses et honteux ce sont
des députés et c'est comme si c'est plus
important d'être député c'est d'avoir le
poste de vue ce président de refus de la
chambre il y a quelque chose d'enfants
presque là-dedans Véronique mais en fait
il y a une solution peut-être que Marc
Tanguay aurait pu explorer premièrement
de proposer cette entente là ça tenait
pas la route parce que dans deux ans si
un nouveau chef qui est choisi il
pourrait très bien dire ben moi je veux
pas que les deux dernières années ce
soit Marc Claude Nikos alors Marc
Tanguay aurait juste pu dire mais
écoutez si on n'arrive pas à s'entendre
au focus soumettez tous les deux votre
candidature au secrétariat de la
Présidence de l'Assemblée nationale puis
on va faire un vote les autres parties
participent à ce vote là alors allez
faire votre lobby auprès du PQ de Québec
solidaire dakaq et que le meilleur gagne
et finalement l'audio reviendra pas au
caucus libéral de trancher parce qu'il y
arrive pas
le français au Nouveau-Brunswick le
français dans les instances fédérales il
y a eu cette histoire ou dans un comité
sénatorial Hélène il y a des gens qui
ont suggéré qu'on ne demande plus la
connaissance du français pourrait être
au diplomate parce qu'on se privait de
gens de qualité je fais entendre des
Acadiens en furie parce que Chris Aston
unilingue anglophone et nommé au comité
qui doit réviser les langues officielles
les francophones ne décolèrent pas on
les écoute on vient
la nomination de Monsieur Christ Austin
au sein du Comité pour la révision des
langues officielles c'est une décision
tout à fait insensible et insensé
l'intention là c'est de réveiller
finalement le côté francophone mais
aussi des nos amis anglophones et
francophiles qui comprennent que nous
revendications ils sont très simples et
c'est pour le mieux pour la province en
vérité on est francophone et comme
francophone au Nouveau-Brunswick peu
importe je pense qu'on doit être
interpellé par ce qui se passe sur la
Loi sur les langues officielles du
Nouveau-Brunswick
oui ça semble une évidence Hélène oui
ben écoutez c'est clair que ça donne
l'impression du loup qui entre dans la
bergerie parce que bon on Chris Aston à
l'époque où il dirigeait le parti de
l'alliance des gens du Nouveau-Brunswick
avait remis en question certains socles
du bilinguisme dans cette province par
exemple les deux systèmes de santé
parallèles un anglais en français dans
les systèmes scolaires bon qui sont déjà
parallèles évidemment mais il y a un
transport scolaire aussi qui est
parallèle un pour les francophones un
pour les anglophones il avait proposé de
fusionner ça pour faire des économies
évidemment les parents francophones
voient ça comme un outil de
d'assimilation alors évidemment que les
francophones reçoivent ça comme une
menace de l'Intérieur en même temps si
je voulais me faire légèrement l'avocate
du diable et je suis même pas certaine
que je voudrais être cet avocate mais ce
que le premier ministre de la province
dit c'est on a toujours eu des guerres
de langue au niveau brandswick donc si
pour reviser la loi autant avoir autour
de la table tous les points de vue afin
que la nature voilà exactement peut-être
que ça se défend mais en bout de piste
ça donne quand même l'impression d'un
certain retour d'ascenseur parce qu'il
faut se rappeler que ce monsieur Austen
il était d'abord et élu au à la tête de
son parti et il a finalement comme
décidé de plier bagage et de se joindre
au conservateur et donc il a eu un siège
au cabinet alors est-ce que c'est une
forme de récompense d'avoir du Premier
ministre on peut quand même se poser la
question mais il y a comme une remise en
question aussi du de la place du
français qui inquiète au
Nouveau-Brunswick plus largement oui
Christian oui surtout qu'au Canada il y
a deux gouvernements qui sont
formellement bilingue le gouvernement
fédéral puis le gouvernement du
Nouveau-Brunswick puis quand on parle du
bilingus à l'extérieur du Québec
beaucoup de gens vont trouver que c'est
bidon sauf évidemment les Francos
ontariens qui sont importants et les
Acadiens au niveau banzaïque là c'est
pas juste théorique le bilinguisme c'est
très enraciné donc c'est inquiétant
c'est une gifle des Acadiens et plus
généralement moi je réfléchis ça après
midi en préparant pour le panel je
trouve que c'est honteux que l'héritier
de Pierre Elliott Trudeau on peut
critiquer pierre et le Trudeau mais
sur le plan canadien son fils a juste un
Trudeau cautionne de plus en plus de
façon évidente en fait le fait qu'on
passe le français au bénéfice des
autochtones nous bénéfices du
multiculturelle sur bénéfice d'un tas de
choses le bilingus mon Canada devient
quelque chose de plus en plus formel de
plus en plus bidon donc moi je trouve ça
honteux c'est comme si c'est quand même
il respecte pas l'héritage de son père
parce que c'est dans la caution c'est
bilingue pour faire des efforts puis on
sent pas on sent aucun on sent Zeld
total pour les autochtones total pour
une musculaires pour un tas de choses
mais pour le français le site
l'indifférence au fond ton on s'est
boucler le loyer c'est marrant il y a un
espoir avec minhalie jolie vous savez à
l'époque où on savait que à Québec qui
avait monsieur Jean-Louis Marette qui
prépare un projet de linguistique mais
les jeunes c'est intéressant à
reconnaissait qu'au Québec c'était
différent on a abandonné ça le prochain
doigt fédéral en matière linguistique
ce projet madame petit spot est-ce que
ça avance est-ce qu'on avance ben
écoutez j'avoue j'ai pas vérifié
récemment ils sont encore en comité
parlementaire donc il y a du travail à
faire dessus mais il y a quand même
beaucoup d'insatisfactions autour de ce
projet de loi-là moi je dirais juste sur
monsieur Trudeau il y a des pots et des
comptes c'est quand même lui qui a dit
que désormais à la Cour suprême il faut
que les juges soient bilingue ça
semblait une évidence mais sous les
conservateurs si on n'avait pas été mais
inversement oui il y en a une gouverneur
général du Canada qui ne parle pas
français et aussi une lieutenant
gouverneur du Nouveau-Brunswick oui ne
parle pas français et ils vont devant
les tribunaux pour défendre ce choix ok
merci beaucoup c'est tout le temps qu'on
a merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne
soirée à la prochaine au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI